e
e e
okay good morning
everybody Welcome to jail
car
um Senator gray you can sit in for
Senator Lang who is not going to be here
today and representative grassy you can
sit in for representative Schmidt and
representative hackin Phillips
for representative
Lon well there's representative Lon in
that case you're in for Senator
Whitley okay wow full crowd today yeah
all right a meeting of the M of the
minutes of the previous meeting does any
does anyone have a
motion V approve second any corrections
changes or
comments seeing none those in favor I
opposed all right
is there anything to be taken off the
consent
agenda all right in that case is there a
motion
second that's tie between Senators
Senator Enis and representative LM to
the representative no I'll defer all
right representative Lyn gets gets the
goal
um any question questions comments
discussion all right the consent agenda
those in favor I
opposed okay moving right is there
anything to be
postponed yes yes the uh um yes letter B
220 2023
236 right from education does someone
wish to Mo move that
second all right move by Senator Ward
second by representative
gr those in favor I
opposed that's
postponed a starting off with explosives
how nice yes uh yes so this is proposal
2023 184 uh the department of safety's
rules on explosives
the only comments I had on this
particular proposal were two notes to
the committee the first has to do with
the dates effective dates on the forms
most of them say April or May of 20 2013
excuse me and because forms are rules
they do have a 10-year expiration date
just like uh rule text does however
after speaking with the department and
looking at our old files it does seem
like all of these forms were part of the
2013 rul making process and those rules
did not go into effect until August um
and this proposal was filed before the
expiration date which stays the
expiration date for all of the rules um
so I just wanted to bring that to the
committee as attention we are working on
the manual and that's something that
we'll try to clarify in the manual that
effective date of forms needs to be um
or when exactly the agency should be
putting the effective dates of forms the
other another note that I had has to do
with uh four of the forms the first is
on page seven which is dssp 84 and the
other three are on page nine all uh four
of these forms originally had asked or
not asked had required a social security
number and after looking at the statutes
I did not see any statutory Authority
for that which would be in violation of
RSA
54122 after the agency submitted their
conditional approval they made that
requirement a voluntary
request and so even though they're not
requiring on the form it is still
something that they're asking um the
applicant to provide even though it's
voluntary so I just wanted to bring that
to the committee's
attention we yes could we have a uh
comment on
that good morning my name is Mart moani
I'm the representative for the
Department of Safety and I have Trooper
Flynn from the um explosives unit
division of State Police as well um and
when I inquired um of the the the
permits and Licensing unit who processes
these applications it's more of a
customer service in the sense that when
an applicant comes in and they provide
their name and address and some of them
from are from out of state they do a
background check and they also check the
state from where they're coming from and
it's a means if somebody has a very
common name of being able to ensure that
it is the same person rather than just
simply denying them based on something
that the record displays and it's not
that
individual question
concerns all
right anything else that is all I had
for this proposal um as I stated it is a
conditional approval um so the committee
can either approve the conditional
approval or um enter an objection at
this time if they feel it's
necessary
represent so I am concerned with the
voluntary divulsion of social security
numbers and I'm wondering if there's
some
[Music]
other um information that could be given
in addition to someone's name and
address from an out of town I I just I'm
not comfortable with that understood um
I I don't know how to respond to that
other than um absent that there's no way
to ensuring that the record belongs to
that individual and they would just be
denied until they were able to prove
that they were that individual with that
record
question does if does do a form ask for
date of birth I mean wouldn't that be a
basis to you know even if it's John
Smith from New Jersey uh presumably it
would be if the date of birth would seem
to be a big way to narrow it down that's
a very good question um so I'm told that
they look for three um indicators to
match and date of birth is one of them
okay
other
questions director moral uh thank you I
do know that there are at least a few
agencies in certain rules who ask for
well request but do not require social I
also have seen a few instances where
they request just the last four of the
social whether those conform with the
law is debatable
okay Senator
Greg I'll
second all right moved by Senator gray
second by Senator Enis comments
questions seeing none those in favor
I
opposed all right thank you
no all right Prime
Wetlands so there's only one comment on
this conditional approval and um it's an
interesting issue uh the statute gives
the commissioner the discretion to
authorize a 40-day extension for good
cause shown that would allow Municipal
conservation local River advisory
committee or the New Hampshire Rivers
Council more time on their
application um the issue is there
there's just no rules regarding what
good CA shown would be um and so either
it needs rules or it needs a legislative
fix um we just thought it was a little
unclear as to when this this extension
would be
given
okay good morning I'm according Lockwood
I'm one of the staff Attorneys at
Dees um so we actually removed from this
chapter the reference to that statutory
provision in in the hopes that that
would fix the situation um it's not
necessarily that we're saying good cause
doesn't need to be defined or explained
in some way it's just that this is not
the chapter to do it so Wetlands has 10
chapters of laws um of roles in order to
um for someone to get a permit when they
need a permit that sort of thing um this
chapter is only for Prime Wetlands which
is only certain permit applications and
so if we were going to Define it we
would put it into chapter 300 which
applies to all permit applications so at
this point for this chapter that's
before you we don't reference that
statutory provision and it just also
wouldn't be the appropriate place to
explain what good causes okay so does
that answer your
concern Madam chair mhm uh because our
court reporter is not here today I would
ask that anybody that comes to the table
regardless of whether they testified
please fill out a pink card oh
sorry and yes that that does answer the
concern okay all right Senator gray
question do you want that approval to
Beal based on them adding the item
to and so I'll make that motion that we
approve on the condition the uh
Department seek to
change chap
300 to include
theary I'll second
that
okay any further comments questions
discussion those in
favor
opposed all right thank you very
much all right right
oplc okay so
um uh this item was postponed from the
last meeting it's the lure and
discipline of regulated profession the
PLC 300 rules um there's been a
conditional approval request and an
amended conditional approval request
filed and most of the issues have been
resolved um there are a few that remain
and those are on the um the final
proposal packet
so and if you go to that packet you'll
see um about three pages in there is a
um a memo to the committee kind of
describing what those remaining issues
are so um I won't spent a whole lot of
time on them two of the issues are
basically informational notes to the
committee um which you've you've heard
about before and that's around the um
and that should be addressed this
legislative session and that's around
the um the the term of the licenses when
they expire and then the other issue is
around the administrative fines in that
uh some boards still have administrative
fines within their um their practice
acts there is um one legislative comment
that you'll find in a couple of
different places and um it's on pages 11
of the of final proposal or um page 17
of the final proposal packet page page
26 of the final proposal or 32 of the
packet so it's the same legislative
comment the rules would allow the oplc
Licensing Bureau to make a determination
on whether to approve or deny a license
application without input from the
applicable board if that board doesn't
respond to the oplc request for feedback
on that application within 50 days as
you may know some boards don't meet
regularly some meet quarterly for
example um RSA 541a 29 requires agencies
to approve or deny applications within
60 days so the oplc is within that you
know that time frame um but what we were
concerned with is that the rules may not
adhere to legislative intent and that's
because um the statute for oplc is
describes that the oplc is supposed to
consult with the boards and so it's
unclear whether sending a request to the
board like this qualifies as Consulting
with and so um we're not sure what the
legislature had in mind around you know
Consulting what that's supposed to look
like and so um that's you know we
weren't really sure of sending the
notification in this way it qualifies as
Consulting with the board so we thought
that you might have some questions about
that before I close I'll say that um the
issue also somewhat impacts the next
proposal on the agenda uh the PLC 313
which are receiving some cards on that
um we didn't have any comments on that
proposal but the reason why it's not on
consent is because we did get some
testimony expressing concern that the
oplc is not actively Consulting with the
boards and so um but we knowe that um in
you know conversation with the oplc what
we learned was that in preparation for
those PLC 313 rules the oplc did solicit
for feedback from all of the impacted
boards and uh gave them a timeline to do
that so anyway we're just not sure what
Consulting with is supposed to mean what
the legislature had in mind and so
that's the issue that remains with this
proposal okay
representa the um Edna committee spent
significant amount of time in the last
two years with
amending the um statutes for
oplc and it was very clear to the
committee that oplc is not to operate
independently from the boards on some
matters and so the in consultation with
the board means that they are to
include comments from the boards on any
actions that they take where that's
written if that needs to be further
defined we can do that but it there is
no um there was no
timeline there was no method for that
process one would think that oplc would
discuss these things at board meetings
for example as opposed to just doing
this electronically through emails
it has to be a sincere
effort director courtley thank you madam
chair members of the committee Lindsay
courney executive director oplc um so I
think our legislative Authority is
pretty clear and actually our
responsibility is to um issue licenses
in accordance with objective standards
established by the boards that's the
criteria that was established in both
hb2 655 and 409 of last year so we are
doing that I think what we're finding is
that there are some rules that are not
necessarily objective and then typically
what we find is that with respect to
criminal history records checks um we
don't have clear uh delegations of
Authority or standing orders from the
boards stating you know these particular
um crimes could be something that's
substantially related to the practice
and so therefore we want to have a
showca hearing so that's where we're
finding the issue what's also clear
under 54a 29a is that the agencies
whether it be the board or the oplc have
to act within 60 days and so our
position has always been that the boards
in addition to oplc have an obligation
to do their job which means convening a
quum of the board if there is an
application that needs to be reviewed I
don't think it's appropriate for a board
to essentially hold hostage the
application process by not meeting um
and I actually think that the statutory
language is quite clear that if if they
don't meet then then there are some um
decisions that are made by operation of
law so that's we don't find ourselves in
that position uh very frequently because
most boards are committed to doing the
business that they're um they have been
entrusted to do by the legislature um
but our position is that under the rare
circumstances where boards can not meet
in a timely fashion um in order to
adjudicate an application then the
agency is obligated to act pursuant to
54 a
29a questions
comments Senator um I I think this
discuss turn your your microne please I
think the discussion here is wonderful
uh but I think the the real solution is
to approve with the condition that they
seek
legislative uh solution to this because
the wording as it is right now
um you know is is at least confusing our
people you know that are reviewing this
so I move
that okay before I'll second all right
move by Senator gray second by
representative um groa I do have a
public comment on PLC 300 oh that's
that's from from director cartney we've
already heard from her the others are on
the
313 okay
any further comments yeah the only thing
I mean I'm I'm certainly prepared to
support Senator Gray's motion but the
only other thing I'd say is it seems to
me that that U the explanation given is
a good one I there's not um unless I'm
missing something there's nothing even
if a board normally meets quarterly
there's nothing that prevents them from
meeting more often if they have work to
do and so it seems to me that your
position is valid you send them
something saying here's a you know we've
just gotten this application now they're
they J is to is to meet and if it's you
know if that if that means they have to
meet more more frequently than quarterly
well that's the way it goes so I I think
that's a perfectly valid explanation yes
I
um how often does
a such a a application come in that it
is obviously correct with a say with a
clear criminal record do you consult
with the board in that case depends on
the board so the Board of Nursing um we
we do often have findings on criminal
history records they've actually done a
matrix that tells us exactly what to do
if you have a if you have a history of
this then this is what you do if you
have a history of this then we want to
see it and they meet very regularly at
least once a month um other boards where
we have uh positive findings and
criminal history records checks they do
not have such a matrix we're working
with them on trying to develop that um
and so essentially as the applications
come in um we upload them into the
agenda and say you have applications
that need to be reviewed which means you
can't conduct a meeting electronically
we don't do this business via V via
email because that's a violation of 91a
what that means is that they have to
schedule a
meeting
but with that with a clear criminal
history you would process the license
without necessarily Consulting with the
board is that correct or not no only if
the board has uh set forth in a standing
order a Del of what they would like to
see because the challenges under
332g there has the crime first of all
the board has to prove by clear and
convincing evidence that um that the the
person is more likely to offend um
reoffend with the license so we can't
unless we have some sort of Delegation
we can't make that showing upon a review
okay so that unless the board has
decided that this is okay you don't just
process a license correct okay correct
unless they don't meet and if they don't
meet then we need to move forward okay
thank you rep representative fellows um
yes thank you I'm wondering if you can
tell me if how often the this issue is
coming up when it's not a criminal
records check and also how much is there
is there a specification of how much
lead time you're supposed to to give the
board to respond and to meet so the
rules the rules that are proposed here
um are intended to comply with 541a 29
which means that as um within 60 days of
receiving a response to a request for
information the agency has to act um and
either approve or deny the application
so as soon as we get the complete
application we essentially upload it
into our electronic system you know most
times most boards have a monthly meeting
so they're they're going to they're
going to be seeing these in a timely
fashion it's just the boards that um
don't meet regularly meet quarterly meet
once a year Meet twice a year that's the
challenge um with respect to whether we
see this on other matters not involving
criminal history records checks um it's
not typical because the boards are
supposed to have objective standards um
there are some boards that still have
subjective standards you still have
essays and that sort of thing and we're
working with them on
those okay other question
repres so I just want to um support the
um motion that Senator Greg made because
this is this kind of conversation is not
one that we had intended when we
reviewed all those um amendments this
summer concerning the authority of the
board to issue licenses so I do think
that we need to look at the legislation
on this to make sure that we haven't
somehow um in intendedly unintendedly
made it more
complicated okay thank you director
moral um I have somewhat of a concern I
understand that the process that
director Courtney mentioned as far as
the board interacting uh with oplc and
setting standards for oplc to act but
I'm concerned whether or not those
things that the board is telling oplc
you know if this happens then it's okay
to approve if they don't have you know
if this is negative and uh do not
approve whether those items are actually
in the board's
rules I don't believe so because I
haven't seen them but we'll director you
have a comment on that they're not in
the board's rules I would say if if
that's the position position of the
committee we can certainly work with
them on that
um we did um we have used these
guidelines um on advice of council over
at the Department of Justice for many
years um if we are required to send
every application with a criminal
history records check for to the board
of nursing for example that is going to
be um that's going to be a lot of work
so I think there's some practical issues
here and we'd be happy to that's the a
directive of the committee we'd be happy
to work with them on rules um but we
have been operating on advice of council
for quite some
time
M comments questions yes director I
think this is a my concern is limited
because presumably each of the boards
have um criteria in their rules for when
they are going to U approve or not
approve of a license it's the concern is
simply if they add add something to that
when they talk to oplc that is not in
their rules which is hypop from the
comments it appears that it's a matter
of how to evaluate an imperfect criminal
records check and that
is something that each board has to
decide for themselves I was just going
to um Echo director Mor's comments you
know to the extent that these
matrices are you know um have required
IR ments that are different from the
rules or that they should be in the
rules then they need to be in the rules
but we don't know that until we see
those
matricies we'll take that under
advisement not to continue to add to the
confusion but there's a lot of crimes
both statutory and under common law and
so what we find is that you know there
are certain buckets that I think the
boards can give us Direction on and the
issue is whether whether the matter
requires consultation that's the issue
so what they've said to us is you don't
need to consult with us on these issues
the rest does require consultation and
we leave those to the boards I I think
and and we can certainly talk offline
but I I I don't know that it would be
possible to put every potential crime
into a rule because there are many um
and then there's aggravating and
mitigating factors that we could
potentially not consider in that process
yes right so so the board could for
example say you have a 20-year-old
possession of marijuana we're not going
to worry about it if you've got a
current uh fenel with intent to sell we
definitely want to talk about it right
right light example well just off the
top of my head thank you all right any
further comments
questions all right we have a motion to
approve with a consultation and that
would be with conditional approval
conditional approval yes those in favor
I
opposed
okay all right PLC
3113 we do have some public comment on
that uh I think we'll hear from the
staff and then the public and then
director Court yes um I have no comments
on this uh proposal the public testimony
that I received
for it um talked about the the the oplc
not Consulting with the board of
acupuncture but it appears that they
were given notice with the letter first
and then were consulted with for 45
minutes about these rules excuse me so
it did not affect my uh analysis of
possible reasons for objection all
right thank you I if I could add one
thing um and taking a look at that
testimony in the letter that the oplc
sent to the acupuncture board um
director uh Courtney did let me know
that that same sort of letter went to
all of the boards prior to them filing
the initial proposal so they did
actively seek out feedback from the
boards on those rules all
right thank
you Michael peler
uh good morning um so I just have a a
comment on the uh propos uh I'm sorry my
name is Michael Peltier I live in
Hillsboro New Hampshire um and I have a
comment on the uh substantially similar
rule for the plumbing board is that okay
we're on target um
so uh I remotely attended the uh board
meeting last week and what the proposal
As I understood it was um is if another
state has um the same year or subsequent
year
um uh Statewide adoption of uh the same
plumbing code the international plumbing
code that New Hampshire aderes to or has
adopted um it's presumed to be
substantially similar um what um my
concern is in that respect if um New
Hampshire uh decides for example later
this year to adopt the 2024
IPC uh what used to be substantially
similar uh considered substantially
similar in the 2021 code is no longer
considered substantially similar uh with
New Hampshire's adoption the 2024 code
so um what I would suggest is not only
the uh current and subsequent codes be
recognized as you know sort of de facto
uh substantially similar but also the
previous year's code
um you know you know one one can observe
that uh the the technology of Plumbing
uh dates back 6,000 years and uh if you
brought a a Roman plumber uh forward in
time to present day he would recognize
the principles of gravity and water
pressure and so on um so I think that um
you know over the past uh several years
uh the technology of of plumbing and the
the rules around uh Plumbing safety uh
have matured and uh I think that uh
recognizing you know uh perhaps previous
year or previous two two uh versions of
the code as well as potentially uh the
uniform pum code um would uh would serve
the interests uh of the legislature in
encouraging uh skill trades people from
other states to move to the great state
of New
Hampshire thank you I will mention that
New Hampshire is deliberately not on the
latest version of the codes we are now
contemplating moving to the 2021 code so
Most states will be with us or ahead of
us so that while valid I think your
concern is less of an issue than it
might be if we were trying to be the
latest greatest
yes but thank you for your comments any
questions okay thank you thank
you Jesse
duet my name is Jesse duet I'm the chair
of the mechanical board um and I'm just
speaking on the 313 as we're here but um
we just talked about it quite a bit in
this past meeting and one of the things
that really stuck out to us was giving
licenses
to pick a state um and the board we
definitely did not like that idea in the
sense
that we're being held to the same
standard as and no offense like
cosmetology um and what we do is a
little bit different there's a lot of
Life Safety involved um when you're
dealing with gas there's a reason we
have a gas law in this state and it's
because bad things happen we are not
making sure that people are being held
to the same standard that we do require
in the state of New
Hampshire um if this is going to be the
way it's going to be we would at least
like to see people come in at least just
test just take the test if if you say
you're a plumber and you know yourself
you should be able to take the test
and the biggest thing that we had a
bigger concern on was New Hampshire law
which there should be some sort of a
Juris Prudence test um and we did vote
in this past meeting to actually start
putting together one um we were not even
aware that that was something that we
could do uh we are now aware of that and
we would definitely like to see I guess
those would be the two biggest things
that if great if you have a license in
another state but
that doesn't mean you know what you're
doing here in New Hampshire so we would
like to see them be able to take the
test and then some sort of a jurist
Prudence
test will you when you develop that
jurist Prudence test will you be
requiring it of New Hampshire applicants
as
well um that is covered in the testing
that they take in the schooling that
they take here in New
Hampshire thank you other questions
okay okay thank you very much for your
testimony Ted
Evans Can't prepare
he's a pro yeah we deal with him
before good morning my name is Ted Evans
I think some of you know me from past
appearances before you uh with me is um
Joy leblan who is a owner of a Plumbing
Heating and electrical
company uh and she's here for moral
support uh so thank you Joy representing
how many heaing air conditioning
Plumbing gas bers Etc other companies
that are on our committee and on our
association with the plumbing gas
Fitters HVAC Association of New
Hampshire so um we attended the hearing
on the proposed um rules for the 33 PLC
31334 to be
specific uh with regard to the
mechanical licensing board and we have
some comments uh further comments uh
based on uh the final version that we've
seen be looking at uh the first thing is
that we appreciate that the references
to the current additions of the code or
later was incorporated in the change in
the rules but we do have some
suggestions on a better way to say it in
in that paragraph one um the original
language that landed in the final
version was those codes adopted by the
legislature in accordance with it with
for residential and Commercial
properties but we think the more precise
thing to do would be to reference the um
definition of the State Building Code in
RSA 155a
paragraph 4 and
4A and the New Hampshire State Fire code
RSA 153 colon 1 paragraph 6A where it
specifies what addition of the code is
currently in law and we think that's a
better way to do that especially because
the legislature is considering moving to
the 21 codes both on the um ICC side the
building code and also on the fire code
which covers the gas so we think that's
a little bit more precise way to word it
we sure the attorneys on the committee
will appreciate
that uh the term residential commercial
is just kind of vague and uh the codes
that we adopt in New Hampshire include
other types of buildings
institutional storage things that aren't
necessarily refer to uh be included in
residential
commercial um paragraph two uh we were
asking for uh at the time what we
thought was a some qualifying event to
verify the applicant is familiar with
the board's administrative rules
especally especially the the 600 rules
uh Etc and um the response was that uh
the board does not appear to require a
jurist Prudence examination so no exam
has been
added subsequent to that we found out
there's a name for this a Juris Prudence
examination we didn't know that at the
time and the board didn't know that now
they know it and they voted to develop
one and our request is that that be
included in this final version of the
rules a juren prudent exam and when the
board has approved one it'll be ready to
be used uh for that
purpose so rather than um delay and make
us go through the the full rule process
for that little change we ask that that
be
included um the reason for this uh part
of some of the reasons for this is the
response said that well uh once they're
licensed uh they'll be going to continue
education and be come uh learned or they
will learn all about their rules and law
in these continuing education
classes but that's really not going to
work first of all it has to be
understood that if if an applicant is
issued a license from another
jurisdiction let's say in June of
24 they'll be able to operate and
practice until June of 26 May or June of
26 before they attend both classes for
both years yes there's a class for each
year but they're not required to to
attend it in that year they can pick up
two classes in the second year that's
and that's I would say maybe 20 30% of
the of the trades people do that they
wait they don't take it every year they
wait until they have to renew oh I have
to get my classes in and then the
providers of this service make both
years classes available so so somebody
could be running around without being
aware of the board's uh administrative
rules
secondly I think it already been pointed
out that the board does have these kinds
of questions covering law and
administrative rules on their
examinations for New Hampshire
applicants so we have to I think make
this equal and safe at the same
time um the part of the reply that said
that in any event professionally the uh
the ly would be professionally obligated
to comply with the applicable code
um I I think that just ignores the
public safety aspect of this licensing
program we're we're installing gas
appliances we're doing plumbing and some
of us do electrical uh and there's a a a
pure Public Safety interest involved
that I think should
overrule um thoughts like oh yeah
they'll just learn and on their way so
uh and just to uh illuminate the board's
600 rules called Professional Standards
um include things like uh what we call
Professional obligations and that is the
things they're required to do uh we have
um ongoing requirements for licenses uh
advertising obligations prohibited
actions what they're not allowed to do
as lenses and then in 608 the duty to
notify and this is an obligation to um
correct uh um situations that are uh a
risk to life
safety and by notifying the owner in
writing uh specifically and then if we
don't get action from the owner they're
supposed to notify a local official or a
Fire official of this dangerous
situation and uh remove the equipment
from service if possible so you don't
see that in other states I'm sorry that
was something that was developed by the
department of safety when we were under
them and it's pretty specific and I
think it really does um lead to the
aspect of public safety I think that we
think that if if this is omitted uh that
we're going to be creating and fostering
unsafe conditions for us in New
Hampshire I'm trying not to get lost
here I'm sorry I I was we were very uh
inclusive in our
comments um
um so number four uh eligibility
requirements for gas fitting
licenses um we made a comment that there
were there were no exams required in the
in the rule writing uh the response was
uh there are no rules for or
requirements for examinations for the
gas fitting we all dropped our Jaws when
we read that because uh that is not was
not our understanding we think that's an
error uh and uh the board's rule uh
requires in MEC 3044 under required
supporting materials for licensing uh in
paragraph G number three proof of
successful completion of the license
exam taken at the end of the courses the
endorsement is being applied so there is
testing um in number five uh we asked
for the inclusion of con continuing
education requirements as uh
constituting the word similar
requirements uh the response was not
reasonable that only individuals from
jurisdictions uh require continuation be
eligible once licensed again they're
obligated to comply with the continuing
education
requirements uh and all lenses are
required to comply with the codes Etc
but we feel perhaps some additional
explanation is necessary the IC C and
NFPA codes the ICC would be the plumbing
code and the NFPA would be the gas code
uh that have been adopted in New
Hampshire are published on a three-year
cycle with new requirements and or
change requ is that a jurisdiction might
have adopted the same code as New
Hampshire now currently but the ly from
that jurisdiction may have been licensed
years earlier under an older addition of
the code or perhaps some other code
entirely it might have been in effect at
the time they were like licensed without
some kind of form of continuing
education on those changes the leny
would not have been required to keep up
with those changes it's possible that
licenses in other jurisdictions are also
issued under grandfathering conditions
which creates more concerns we have
continuing aging requirements once they
are licensed here but the but again they
can be here for quite a while before
getting up to speed uh and it might take
a while excuse me quite a while to get
up to speed if relying only on
continuing education classes and the
so-called professional
obligations uh as you might be able to
tell we were not fans of this change in
the legislation legislation giving out
licenses to other jurisdiction license
holders um and and we're not the same as
cosmetology or massage therapy please
understand we have a serious Public
Safety concern here about this licensing
and I think thank you entertain any
questions okay thank you other
questions Madam chair just so everyone
knows if you take a look at page 31 of
the FP packet um these comments relate
to PLC
yes that's on my sheet in the
top right that's professions regular
ated by the mechanical licensing board
yes that's that's
there okay other uh any other questions
or
comments thank you very much for your
testimony director courney
thank you madam chair Lindsay Courtney
executive director office of
professional lice Insurance
certification um so a couple of things I
just want to um set the stage this the
results uh these rules are a direct
result of the legislation that e folks
passed last year HB 594 which
essentially requires the office to issue
a license to individuals who are
licensed and in good standing in another
state uh with substantially similar uh
requirements as determined by the
executive director enroll in
consultation with the board's councils
and commissions so we um and and I think
as you may recall This was um very high
priority on the governor's uh
initiatives for last year and an effort
to reduce barriers to Workforce um and
allow qualified people to enter um
Workforce in New Hampshire in a
reasonable time frame so initially we
had some interm roles we identified
several professions I think about 10 um
that we thought uh would have the
greatest impact and we focused on those
we filed some interm rules in October
those rules have expired as of April
12th um So currently we have no
endorsement requirements in the state of
New Hampshire and then what we did is um
taking Our obligation to consult with
the boards very seriously is that I went
through every Statute in New Hampshire
and developed a draft of what I thought
would be substantially similar based on
the stat statutory requirements I sent
an individual letter to each board prior
prior to filing the IP in October I
asked for um feedback and or meeting um
and many boards we did meet with I did
meet with mechanical I met with
acupuncture I met with many boards who
were interested in participating in this
conversation sometime around January we
filed the IP again we notified the
boards this was our draft uh and we
invited additional comments so I do
believe that we um did everything we
could to fulfill the statutory
requirement that we consult with the
boards and we did incorporate the
feedback HB 594 requirements are not
specific to certain professions they
apply to all professions as long as
they're substantially similar
requirements so not only does it apply
to Mechanical it applies to cosmetology
massage but it also applies to
Physicians it applies to pharmacists it
applies to also other safety sens
position so the directive from the
legislature was very clear if there are
professions in other states that are
substantially similar to our professions
and our requirements here we are to
issue a
license the statute was also clear that
the really the only requirement is that
they have a license and good standing in
another state we have existing statutory
authority to establish fees so we
thought okay at least they have to fill
out an application and pay a fee and the
statute also said that if the person is
required to undergo a criminal history
records check in New Hampshire to get an
initial license we're going to require
that of our endorsement applicants there
is no language that would authorize the
office to uh impose additional
requirements um but what we and and so I
think we are taking some Liberty with
respect to Juris Prudence exams but the
position we took with the boards is that
if the board has an existing Jance
prints exam if the laws in New Hampshire
de deviate significantly or impose
additional requirements that people need
to be aware of in order to practice
safely we're going to try to put that in
the role and a prime example of that is
psychology or the other Mental Health
Professions where there's different
there's there's differences in the law
for practice purposes as to duty to
notify duty to inform confidentiality
requirements so we thought that was
reasonable that said I think an argument
could be made that we don't have that
seary Authority so that's the position
we took with the boards um that if you
have an existing Prudence exam and it is
based on specific New Hampshire law and
not just a smoke screen for another
licensing examination then we will we
will add that so that that's basically
how this played out originally with
respect to Mechanical we didn't have a
requirement that the code be um the same
addition or later that was added after
we consulted with the boards and at
their request and I think that's
reasonable um to do so
um but the mechanical licensing board
does not currently have a Juris Prudence
exam I would be I would be happy to put
that in in the rules uh if in when they
develop a Juris Prudence exam that
applies to all applicants um but if we
were to add that in the rules now I
think that would uh impede our ability
to actually issue licenses under PLC 313
is because they haven't developed the
the licensing examination so my
suggestion is that if and when they do
develop this JP exam and it it is
specific to newtra law that we go back
and we uh open up the rules again um and
we add that requirement um to the
rules I think that's all I wanted to say
so thank
you okay Senator agay wondering got any
comments on this side of the room no we
have no comments
then I move to approve
second I'd like to add to that
um that if a jurist Prudence exam is
developed it be added to the rule in a
timely
manner I accept that
Amendment thank
you U I did have a question for director
Courtney the testimony IND ated that
the there is a test for gas Fitters as
part of the their licensing
procedure is that something that needs
to be added or ought to be uh ought to
be
added so I think so I think the test it
so the statute doesn't specifically
require an examination and that's what
we were looking at as a statutory
requirements interestingly what we found
during our analysis is that some board
by either practice or rule had
established um requirements that
exceeded what was authorized by Statute
and so that that has facilitated some
additional discussions I think the
examination piece is part of the actual
program and the education requirements
so when we did the analysis um it wasn't
a statutory requirement um I that is
feedback that I had not personally
received um so I mean we would be open
to adding an examination but our
understanding is that the examination is
at the conclusion of the course and is
part and parcel of the course and is not
a separate standardized
examination do does the mechanical
licensing board have the authority to
add requirements in addition to those in
statute because some boards do and I
don't believe all of them do I don't
know that answer off the top of my head
representative representing fora so I do
have a question if for example there is
a Jud jurist Prudence test that is
accepted how do
we it would be put in
rules and then you would come forward to
How would how does that happen what's
the mechanism for that so many boards
have Juris Prudence exams and many
boards have drafted them on their own um
we've we've tried to get away from that
and actually utilize experts in drafting
tests because because that can be that's
a specific technique and what we do is
we have a contract where um we're moving
all of those exams uh to a contractor to
be able to allow the the applicant to
access the test at any given time um so
they don't have to wait quarterly to
take the examination so the requirement
to take the jurus Prudence exam is put
forth in rules but the actual questions
are are not but this but the scope of
the test is as specified by the board
the scope of the task has specified the
board a true jurist Prudence exam will
be about New Hampshire laws what we've
seen in reviewing some of the exams is
that there's they're about New Hampshire
law and then they're about the practice
of the profession so we're trying to get
the boards to limit it to to New
Hampshire laws and specifically their
rules thank you other
questions
comments thank you for your time okay
okay M Mr ranard you're wishing to
testify and didn't bother to turn your
card in
earlier thank you madam chair my name is
Step ranor I'm a license electrician
state of Hampshire and represent the
ecba electrical contractors Business
Association I just was from a procedural
standpoint I would just hope that the
board would consider this the committee
that we've been told to many of us that
a lot of these things are not in our law
and Courtney is right the executive
director is right if you look in the law
it's not in there the procedure has been
for the 40 years I've been licensed that
you put the basic in the law you defined
it in the rules houseful 594 554 which
passed last year which made these
widespread changes okay happened and now
we're now we're getting that kind of
pushed back at us but they didn't do
anything to fix it there's not been
enough time to fix the laws many of the
boards have the same thing so I just
hope the committee considers that
because we're putting this through
saying oh it's not in the law it's not
in the law because we didn't do anything
there's been no effort to try to fix the
law just tell us it's not in it we ran
into the same thing with some education
we worked through some Waring with them
that isn't the best we want but it was
it was compromised and that's what you
have to do but so there hasn't been any
time to fix the rules and put the stuff
in the law that they want we're just
looking at this legally when for 30
years and 40 years it's been like this
so maybe this committee maybe the
legislature can try to fix that and
before we just sweep through this maybe
you look at addressing some of these or
at least going forward I just think that
we keep talking about it's not in the
law not in the law but it never was the
change happened and now we're here we
never had time to fix the law so so what
sort of thing are you saying is not in
the law that you believe needs to be in
the licensing procedure for an
electrician the for an electrician in
general continue education is important
like I said there's a big gap there when
that happens we have 19 amendments right
now with the electrical so if they come
in and they're not aware of them and
they're not installing by him we just
had a situation in one of the town where
somebody installed above and beyond the
code because it was amended out and now
they're having troubles with it I know
you'll be surprised arals right and so
these are important to continue
education for us and again we worked it
out there was a schooling hours um she
did meet with the board the executive
director and they came to an agreement
so what they did is we tried listed the
schooling hours as a requirement with
the substantial equivalent which was
less than what's required and our rules
right now but something that was
substantially equivalent and we were
told we can't put it in there because
our law doesn't say it so we the
compromise was they put it into the top
part PLC
31324 is the section for us and they
added it in so it's part of the 8,000
hours now so technically they only need
7,400 hours of OJT and they could in
five 60 hours of school not the 8,000
hours of OJT and schooling and I'm just
giving you this as an example this is so
it it goes throughout all of the boards
and professions as you've seen with the
mechanical and stuff it's not just us we
jumped ahead with hille 594 and then
never gave it a chance to catch up
saying okay for now on we need all these
things in the law okay ours is clearly
defined in rules what the schooling
requirement is the Bo decides how many
hours safety blah blah
blah previously the legislature didn't
want all that information a lot because
every time there's a little change you
got to come back to the legislature to
do it so I just would hope the committee
considers that going forward to all this
and take that into account before we
just push it Forward because it's not in
our law I would say that having only
7500 hours of Hands-On work and 500
hours of education is substantially
similar that's why we came to a
compromise I'm not disagreeing you know
it's we don't we don't want to insists
that we'll only accept people from
states that have identical requirements
we want to say it covers the same
material it's substantially similar
that's but the education part is
important with the that and you made
that point and it's it's agreed yeah but
it's not in our laws because it wasn't
necessary to be in the laws before and I
agree substantial equivalent we talked
about defining that and there was much
discussion about it there is ways to be
clear with that make it very easy easy
but you can just put time frames in you
know if you've been licensed for 10
years ours even has it in our RSA I
believe are the rules that if you've
been licensed for 10 years that
qualifies you to come and get reciprocal
you don't have to have all that stuff so
you know experience does count in our
particular section it talks about they
have to be license in their state for a
year so that covers the additional 2,000
hours that they would have so that was
why the compromise was made and we
appreciate lindsy working with us and
coming up with that but just wanted you
to realize that it's never going to be
in the law because it's changed too fast
that's there's a lot going on thank you
okay thank you for your testimony any
other comments
questions Mr Evans you you wish to speak
again Madam chair if I could for just a
second um if you look at Mr Evans
testimony on item number one um he makes
a recommendation to change the rules
there uh currently it requires that the
um licensing jurisdiction of the State
shall use the same addition or later of
the same plumbing and fuel gas codes I
don't think that's exactly the same as
the State Building Code and fire code
that he has referenced in his
recommendation for language actually the
plumbing code is part of the State
Building Code okay and the gas code is I
believe part of the state fire code
perfect um and we are in the process of
updating both of
those Mr Evans I just want to respond to
a comination that a comment that uh the
director made that there is no Authority
for license examinations in the
law under 15329 titled examinations
licenses and it basically says the
board shall established through
rulemaking pursuant to RSA 54 541a the
nature of the examinations required for
issuance of fuel gas fitter licenses and
plumbers licenses the scope of such
examinations and the methods of
proceeding proced shall be prescribed by
the board and this may include an
outside organization approved by the
board so they are required so what what
is that citation again please I'm
sorry the citation is uh RSA 153 col 29
paragraph
1 okay
so has the board done so
yes you can let the there is still here
or not but uh I think he would agree
that we do license for all examinations
plumbing and gas
fitting okay so I was surprised to see
that and I was surprised to hear the
director say that that's all I have okay
director Courtney
Lindy cording executive director oplc um
I did um not include this previously but
we are happy to um modify
313 um. 34 to specifically reference the
actual rsas we're happy to do that I
agree that I think that's more
transparent and easier for the public um
with the respect to the examination
issue I think the challenge that and I'm
happy to add past the state approved
examination I I think for gas feds the
challenge is we don't have an actual so
we have a contract right now and
everybody who um takes uh takes the
Examination for journeyman for example
they go through that contract it's a
state standardized test what I
understand and Mr Evans can correct me
if I'm wrong is that the examination is
given as part and parcel of the actual
course and so they may not it's not
necessarily one Statewide exam that
everybody has to take if we want to add
pass a state approved examination we can
do that for those who are endorsing in
um based on the RSA that he referenced
but I think I think that's currently the
challenge the scope of our contractual
obligations for standardized tests does
not include um gas Fitters the other
thing that I would mention and just
briefly is I think what we're I think
what you're probably seeing is that um
as Authority has shifter of the office
we're we're we're diving into the
statutes and we're seeing um that uh
there's been some what I call regulatory
drift you know there's been some um
historic practices that don't
necessarily line up with statutory
Authority and specific to electricians
for example their statute authorized
them to give credit um toward the 8,000
hours for education but it doesn't
require education and so when we are
looking at the statutes in terms of
what's substantially similar we can't
require that the other state um require
education because we don't require
education and that's been the historic
practice but that's that's actually a
deviation from statute I can't in good
faith uh make it you know make an
argument that we should just continue
the practice and so I think what um what
we're currently working on is really
trying to come together with the boards
to clean up the sor practices um that
deviate from statute either by changing
the statute to be in accordance with the
intent is or by modifying the rules but
obviously that that takes that takes
time
okay okay further comments
questions okay we have a motion to
approve the rule with
the uh addition that the Juris Prudence
exam
once uh included will be once developed
will be
included Madam chair did you want to add
um um director Courtney had said that
she was willing to amend to include the
reference to the statutes um in that
section uh
31334 I'll make that motion if we need a
motion well
I'll Senator gray you'll accept that
well he's he's ah well that is a shame
on his behalf on his behalf yes thank
you all right any further comments
questions
discussion representative fellows is in
for Senator gray since he Ste out May I
just clarify do you want me to add the
state approved exam piece for
gasfitters can you know can I can I just
raise a question on that I I I guess I
have a concern that if we do that that
that may be inconsistent with the the
sort of intent of the statute in other
words it you know and I obviously I have
no expertise in this area but I the the
only analogy I can come to is the bar
exam if you say that we're going to
allow people from uh from other state to
become lawyers in New Hampshire as long
as they take the bar exam that's that's
a big discouragement to having out of
state lawyers come to New Hampshire so I
would think that it would be more that
the more appropriate thing would be that
you and I assume you've done this you
would look into what are the
requirements in the in the other states
to determine whether it's substantially
similar and for example if you have to
take an exam in New Hampshire presumably
you would you would you know the other
state that you're going to let somebody
in they would have an exam that was
generally similar to the exam you have
to take in New Hampshire I mean is that
the process you generally are following
and that's what we did and we did
consult with the boards and determining
the jurisdictions um that are
substantially similar and we are
reviewing them on an annual basis so I I
guess I would I would tend to think that
the requirement that you take an exam um
might might be inconsistent
with with the idea of the of the statute
if it's to encourage you know allowing
allowing other out of sters to come in
particularly if the test in question is
at the completion of the training
so it
basically is the confirmation that
you've completed the training rather
than a separate test as the um there is
a separate test for plumbers and and uh
electricians maybe what I can do is um
take this back and when I talk to the
board and work with the board on their
jurist Prudence exam issues with respect
to Plumbers um we can evaluate the gas
Fitters I'm not sure that that I'm not
sure moving forward in the future that
that's the model that they would like to
use in terms of having the test at the
conclusion of the program so we can we
can work with them on that I will say
lnas are very similar to that um there
so there is a model in New Hampshire for
that okay thank you any further cor
director moral I would add to at least
from a legal standpoint if you put a
requirement in that say you shall pass
an exam and an exam doesn't currently
exist then they can't comply with that
requirement I me why the the request is
that when the Juris Prudence exam is
available it be added I I know the
committee has sometimes approved a rule
that says you shall comply with this
other Rule and the other rule is still a
couple of months out but uh you know
that's a case by case
determination okay all right any further
comments um to be clear this is uh
conditional approval based on the change
in 313 34 which was adding the
statute um and then with the
understanding that when Juris Prudence
exams are added they will be timely
added to the rules correct correct okay
correct all right everyone understand
yep all right those in
favor those
opposed all right thank you very much
and I'm really impressed we got this out
in barely a year after we passed that
law all right and Department of
energy so this one is actually a
conditional approval and um I worked
with the Department to um come up with
what they need what they need is an oral
conditional approval um that's to change
in the very first paragraph of the rule
it says nothing in this rule or this
part shall be construed
and it's it will be changed to um
nothing in this rule is to be
construed um that's removing the sh
because shs do not belong in purpose
statements um and then down on page 10
of the rule uh Ian
1541 B we're also changing that may uh
to to a shall so the department shall
condition any license issued under this
paragraph in any manner the department
finds necessary to ensure that the
license is likely to be exercised
safely paragraph C is the same thing
we're changing the May to a shall so
using a non adjudicative process the
department of energy shall reject
incomplete or improperly filed
applications so those are the only
changes that still need to be made so
this would be a conditional approval
with the added oral conditional approval
for this role okay is there any
other questions comments is the agency
here could you turn your microphone on
please thank
you there is that
better again Andrew Haron Department of
energy and I think um it was just the
intention to also state in
C um it would say and shell also using a
non adjudicative process issue or deny a
license within 90 days of reeding
receiving a comp you know what strike
that yes that's correct um it it's above
that NC what was left out was unless an
application is cured upon request by the
department just wanted to make sure that
language was was what was agreed upon
and we do we do a agree entirely with
the changes and um would ask for an oral
CA okay I hope that was clear I hope I
made it more clear rather than less
thank
you all right questions is there a
motion so moved second all right move by
Senator inis second by representative ly
discussion those in favor I I
opposed okay there's energy
AJ Jo uh so the final one on today's
agenda is 20247 from the Department of
Health and Human Services treatment of
specific types of income the only
comments I had on this proposal is that
all of the um section except for two
paragraphs have been expired since June
12th of
2023 um
section A the only paragraph that
remains is A7 but the whole section has
to do with the types of income to be
excluded for eligibility
purposes and section B which is all
expired is how certain types of income
shall be treated and then paragraph C
which is also expired has to do with the
treatment of supplemental security
income how that will not be counted or
shall be counted as unearned income for
uh fan if assistance so that was the
only comment I had on this
proposal good morning Nicole Valena
Department of Youth and Health
Department of Health and Human
Services um yes regrettably this is an
example again where years ago you could
open up just one paragraph and sub
paragraph and make an edit um and it
Alters The Source note and so yes
Department of Health and Human Services
did um miss that and when it was
realized began Ru making we're here if
you have
questions and have
you enforced this this rule while yeah
we did continue business as usual it was
in the best interest of the client there
would have to have been an entire system
overhaul um with our programs and such
so business continued as usual it was
realized Ru making began and we are here
um and do not plan to we're glad that
there's no longer opening up a paragraph
or a sub paragraph for editing in entire
sections moving
forward I believe some of these
requirements are actually in federal law
too lovely we all browse through federal
laws in our spare time yes other uh
questions comments does somebody have a
motion second okay move by represent L
on second by represent groa further
discussion those in favor I those
opposed thank you and I do hope you're
scouring your rules for similar cases we
yeah I mean honestly we have 3,000 rules
there's two of us in the rules unit and
our um program areas of course do rules
in addition to everything else they do
but we are working very hard with every
program area um it is sometimes really
hard to catch these ones because when
you're even looking at the source note
then you have to go and research the
actual rule to find out which part was
amended it's not just there on gen court
so um It's Not Our intention to let
things
expire thank you all right anyone
else do we have any other
business right I direct no uh nothing
other than consideration of the
continued meeting I don't think we need
one does anyone okay we will not have a
continued meeting this month all right
anything
else in that case we are adjourned